one of my favorite comedies uh of the
last you know whatever 15 years uh is
Forgetting Sarah Marshall I think it is
such a perfect comedy and I I think many
comedies come close or they can come
they get halfway there that is so sweet
and so nice and so funny every time I
watch it thank you and uh so my wife and
I that's one of our like if that movie's
on we are watching it cool and I like
seeing you naked
um that movie is really honest I honest
like I think that that's why I wasn't
trying to be funny as crazy as that
sounds I got dumped while I was naked
and so I put that into a movie okay this
is what I want to ask you about because
I've always heard that you wrote you
were 24 I think when you wrote the
screenplay and that you wrote it very
quickly yeah based on a real breakup is
that true yeah I I
uh
um I was dating somebody who's amazing
I'm like super in love and um
they had to go away for a little while
and they came back and uh called me from
the airport and said uh hey can I come
over and as a adolescent young man I
thought that meant like we've been a
part I need to have sex yeah so
oh man she arrived at the house
and I had decided that the way to really
like kick off this sex yeah was that I I
was waiting on the couch totally naked
like post like comedically post like a
bottle a woman in a bottle baby yeah
I'm going with bought a job Reubens yes
you go with your birthday
I can remember like I'm remembering it
viscerally now because so she walked in
and there I am laying and I said uh I've
got a surprise for you
and then she said we need to talk and
you are as vulnerable yeah as any mammal
can be yeah yeah and I'm I'm fairly
confident that it's not the end of the
sentences we need to talk this sex is
gonna be wonderful
right right and so this like breakup
starts and I'm naked and the whole time
I'm I think this is like maybe the
problem
I'm thinking like this is so funny this
is going to be amazing when I write it
as it's happening it's happening you are
thinking this is screenwriter's goals it
was absurd like it was absurd what was
happening and then a part that didn't
make the movie
wrote it in but it was too long when we
made it uh I stopped in the breakup and
I said
I need to put on clubs and she said okay
and so I went into my bedroom and then I
spent like 25 minutes picking out an
outfit
yes I'm like taking shirts off and
throwing them on the ground and trying
pants on that don't quite fit right okay
it comes out in the tux I came out I
came in about six times it's pretty
woman I came out in a button-up blue
shirt and a tacky pants a blockbuster
and then I said I'm wearing your
favorite outfit oh
yeah wow body blow after body blow yeah
and so there was that and then
simultaneously like during that period I
I am admittedly like a weird dude and
I've Loved puppets since I was young and
I was writing a Dracula puppet musical
to be like this is this will show them
right I remember going over I finished
my first draft of the Dracula puppy
music I recorded all the music by myself
in my apartment oh sure it was really
special and I called Apatow and I said I
have to show you something and I went to
his house and naked
you gotta stop doing that it's not
helping yeah I played him the CD and he
listened really patiently and then he
said uh you can't show this to anybody
ever oh wow and uh yeah and and then it
just like stayed in in you know on the
computer and then years later when I
wrote for getting Sarah Marshall
I said I'm ending it with this puppet
musical Judd and he said it's your movie
do it and uh like everything about that
movie is really authentic to who I was I
love the cast so much I mean I love
everybody in the cast and Mila who I
know
personally she's such a lovely person
she's a life force she's so fantastic in
that film there's so many things I love
about it and I have to tell you every
time I watch that I want to see more of
the musical because the musical I mean
the music is really good and I always
want to see more of the Dracula puppet
movie and Van Helsing and I mean the
whole thing is it's really fun I had a
plan recently remember when um
lin-manuel Miranda released the like
making of um Hamilton I wanted to do
like a kind of a mockumentary of the
making of a taste for love that showed
Peter bringing it to Broadway and like
all the behind the scenes maybe one day
you should do that yeah it'll be fun
it'd be fantastic so I'm curious you you
wrote that movie uh very quickly and how
soon afterwards did it get made did a
bunch of years go by or was it it got
made the next year Knocked Up came out
while I was writing that
um
and then basically I think that Judd
when Freaks and Geeks got canceled and
had a like kind of Monte Cristo Revenge
Mission like I I'll show him a kind of a
recurring theme you know you were wrong
to cancel the show I'm going to
systematically make these people stars
to show you how dumb you are I think
that that like really was part of the
motivation yeah I think he also felt
some responsibility because we were you
know just out of high school or high
school kids who he kind of plucked out
and
some people didn't go to school you know
as a result of doing Freaks and Geeks uh
so that movie got made like the year
after I wrote it